Speaker 1: We are watching the real time panic
and collapse of aspects of the Republican Party,
in particular, much of the Trumpian wing of
the Republican Party. Donald Trump's former
press secretary, Kayleigh MCENANY, in reaction to
the disastrous midterm results for Republicans,
particularly MAGA Republicans and some of the
critical Trump endorsed people on Fox News said
Trump should not announce that he is running for
president on Tuesday. Kayleigh MCENANY is telling
Trump, cancel the announcement, at least postpone
it because of what happened on Tuesday and the
fact that Republicans now need to figure out how
do you win in Georgia? MCENANY Also even saying
Trump shouldn't even campaign for Herschel Walker.
It should be Ron DeSantis. A very different
Kayleigh MCENANY than the one that prayed at the
altar of Trump when, of course, she was paid for
him as as it makes sense to do. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: And that could go straight through the
state of Georgia on reports that include Trump.
I think he needs to put it on pause. Absolutely.
Look, he'll make that decision or make his own
decision, but does he go too far? I'm advising
any contender. DeSantis, Trump, whomever. No one
announces 2024 until we get through December six.
Do you see the former president? I need for him to
go to Georgia. I think we've got to make strategic
calculations. Governor DeSantis, I think he should
be welcome to the state given what happened last
night. You've got to look you've got to look at
the realities on the ground. And Herschel Walker,
we've got to win the Senate. That's it. Guy's
got to win the Senate. All right. We'll move on.
Speaker 1: Now. Understand? Yes, to some degree.
Announcing that you're running for president when
it's not even clear who won the Senate is a
bad look for anyone. That is absolutely true.
And that's not specific to Trump. But there's
a bigger story here, which is it appears as
though Trump would not even be useful to Herschel
Walker in Georgia. It's not clear to me. In fact,
let me put it a different way. It is clear to me
that if Trump does a rally for Herschel Walker,
I don't think it helps Herschel Walker at all at
this point in time in Georgia. And we're going to
be doing everything we can to activate to get
that get that seat held by Raphael Warnock.
But will Walker tell Trump to stay away?
That would be interesting to see. Will Ron
DeSantis go? Because remember, Ron DeSantis
won by 19. He overperformed the polls almost
two weeks, winning by 19 instead of I think
it was 11, which was the poll's projection.
And he's in the neighboring state of Florida.
He's way more popular at this point. The betting
markets, in fact, let's let's check what
the betting where the betting markets are
right now. As of yesterday, they looked quite
good for for Ron DeSantis, Republican nominee.
As of this point in time. It's actually tightened
up a little bit. It's now tightened up. DeSantis
and Trump basically leaving everybody else
behind. The betting markets now feel that this is
basically DeSantis versus Trump. So it's not clear
that Trump would help. Trump may actually hurt.
This is a race that Republicans need. And Kayleigh
MCENANY is saying Trump shouldn't even announce on
Tuesday. There are, although the event on Tuesday
has not been canceled. There are rumblings that it
is not just Kayleigh MCENANY telling Trump to
hold off on announcing that he is running and
if Trump indeed decides not to go forward with
that on Tuesday. I think it will be very quietly
announced and then rescheduled for some future
point. I also have viewers writing to me saying,
David, I'm not convinced Trump's really going
to run. Trump announced the November 15 thing
before seeing the results of the election. Now
that he has seen them, he might not run. Now,
if Trump were normal, that might be plausible
as the epitome of the ultimate narcissist. I
don't know that the results will actually
dissuade Trump. We're going to wait and see.